[Música]
en directo América es hora de la
información económica por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañero Luis
Méndez urich Hola Luis Buenas noches
bienvenido iniciamos en Europa porque
países de ese continente prometieron
nuevas ayudas para moldavia así es
estamos hablando de una nación soviética
sin salir al mar y considerada como la
más pobre dentro de Europa que ya le
advirtió a su población que se prepare
por un invierno duro debido a los
problemas de energía que atraviesa tras
el conflicto entre Rusia y Ucrania que
ha encarecido los precios de la energía
para paliar la situación los países
europeos prometieron durante una
conferencia de donantes en París una
serie de recursos para lidiar Con el
impacto de la Guerra de Ucrania y el
aumento de los precios de los alimentos
y la energía moldavia sufre apagones
masivos también grandes flujos de
refugiados y posibles amenazas a la
seguridad por la guerra en la vecino
Ucrania bueno y pasamos a Hungría porque
en ese país fue encontrado un yacimiento
claro una agradable noticia en medio de
toda esta situación que se genera con
Rusia su principal proveedor de
hidrocarburoso y de los que Hungría
depende en su totalidad o en gran parte
de ella el anuncio fue realizado por la
empresa petrolera Molly podría aumentar
la producción del país en un 5% el de
yacimiento fue encontrado en la
localidad de peces en una zona cercana
budapest donde comenzaron las
perforaciones el pasado mes de junio
datos extraoficiales señalan que Hungría
produjo en 2021 entre 16.000 y 17.000
barriles de petróleo al día e importó
alrededor del 85% del gas y el 65% del
petróleo que consumió procedente de
Rusia escuchemos que dijeron
está aquí en Hungría lo producimos aquí
en Hungría la extracción no depende de
nadie solo de nuestros colegas no hay
mayor seguridad que esta cuando se trata
de la seguridad del suministro el
petróleo que producimos en Hungría el
gas natural que producimos en Hungría Es
realmente una tierra Dorada la tierra es
Dorada para nosotros es Dorada para los
consumidores es Dorada para el país y
por último pero no menos importante la
tierra es Dorada para el presupuesto
bueno pasamos a Asia porque en Taiwán se
vieron afectados los pedidos de
exportación la situación que se presenta
básicamente por los problemas en China
quienes su mayor comprador y que produjo
una caída por séptimo mes consecutivo en
el mes de octubre según datos publicados
el lunes los analistas apuntan a niveles
crecientes de inflación la débil demanda
en el extranjero que está relacionada
con los casos de Kobe 19 y las
interrupciones en la cadena de
suministro los pedidos que se enviarán
desde Taiwán a China continental y Hong
Kong alcanzaron solo
10.500 millones de dólares el mes de
octubre un 26,7% menos que el mismo
periodo del año anterior esto según los
datos del Ministerio de asuntos
económicos de Taiwán bueno y Hablamos
ahora de Estados Unidos Porque existe
preocupación respecto a la posibilidad
de que se produzca una huelga de
trabajadores en los trenes de carga en
ese país Así es la preocupación guarda
relación con el tema inflacionario Por
qué Pues porque de producirse la huelga
en teoría el 5 de diciembre se elevarán
los precios y estos podrían recaer en el
bolsillo de los consumidores de acuerdo
con lo informado por uno de los
principales sindicatos el que aglutina
la mayor cantidad de trabajadores este
habría rechazado una propuesta de
acuerdo y piden mejoras en los horarios
calificados de exigentes y además piden
aliviar los recortes de empleo en la
industria en septiembre pasado otros
sindicatos ya lograron aprobar algunos
acuerdos Y este lunes y su propio el
sindicato de ingenieros por el momento
los trabajadores de carga permanecerán
en su puesto de trabajo mientras se
mantienen las negociaciones hoy si vamos
a cerrar con la cifra económica del día
tiene que ver en este caso con los
600.000 barriles de petróleo al día que
estima producir Ecuador para el año 2025
Claro está esto tiene que ver con una
serie de inversiones que el país
requiere en algunas zonas del país
Muchas gracias por esta ampliación
económica lo invito a que continúe con
nosotros que ya Seguimos aquí en directo
América con directo